[Music]
gratulations on getting picked up by NBC
for a Brooklyn nine-nine next season how
did this process come about well the
show is owned by nbc/universal always
was but we aired on a different network
thankfully we're very grateful to them
and then it didn't make sense for them
anymore so then the owner of the show
was like you know we have a network and
they scooped us up it's a Christmas
miracle this is gonna shake up the vibe
at all at Brooklyn nine-nine you guys
have such an amazing already like
standing aesthetic to the show well
thank you I don't think we're gonna
change it too much
I believe we're able to do bleeps and
blurs now so I'm looking forward to
returning to that it's basically
everything I did at SNL yeah but
otherwise I think we're just staying the
course but you know there's stories in
progress on our show and we're so
excited to get to keep doing them had so
many great guest stars on Brooklyn
nine-nine
is there anyone that's still on your
bucket list I mean yeah definitely come
into mind I mean probably just the
entire cast of this is us if they would
guest stars
we're not charlie was on he was so good
I'm gonna say something controversial
I think Sterling's good at acting whoa
let's not get ahead of yourself your
eyes peeled for that guy he's gonna be
doing stuff that would be cool but you
get everyone from this is us just to
play a completely different role or just
all of them if they have the time to
just one by one walk through the back of
a shot like a conversation here and then
they just keep sort of funneling by sure
I'm sure that's gonna happen oh I would
say no okay Never Say Never Never Say
Never show got picked up and safe so I
think it's good yeah yeah anything's
possible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]